welcome to GK Essentials where we
explore Basics and useful tips for
getting up and running with gke I'm
kazlyn Fields a developer advocate here
at Google Cloud where I focus on gke and
open source kubernetes
in this episode of GK Essentials we'll
take a look at a key element of your gke
observability Google Cloud managed
service for Prometheus
[Music]
Prometheus is an open source tool for
monitoring and alerting it's part of the
cncf and one of the most used monitoring
tools in the cloud native ecosystem
however managing your own Prometheus
infrastructure can be challenging it can
be tough to scale horizontally as
cluster size and the number of
applications grow as your workload scale
it becomes both critically important and
can be quite difficult to get a single
pane of glass showing traffic across
multiple regions where your application
is deployed
it's also an ongoing workload for your
operations team it's one of those things
you need but running it doesn't directly
provide value to your customers that's
where Google Cloud managed service for
Prometheus comes in Google Cloud managed
service for Prometheus is Google Cloud's
fully managed multi-cloud solution for
Prometheus metrics it lets you globally
Monitor and alert on your workloads
using Prometheus without having to
manually manage and operate Prometheus
at scale it gives us the best of both
worlds you have the familiar interfaces
of Prometheus backed by Google's Planet
scale Monarch time series database
Monarch is the same database Google uses
for monitoring everything Google does
including search YouTube maps and even
Google Cloud itself plus it's backed by
a globally distributed team of Google
sres
managed service for Prometheus stores
all data in Cloud Monarch which means
you get fully managed globally
distributed Planet scale storage of all
your time series data
manage service for Prometheus thin wraps
Monarch with Prometheus compatible apis
both for writing metrics and reading
metrics
and because this is the same Monarch
instance used by Cloud monitoring you
can query over 1 500 Google cloud system
metrics using promql right alongside
your Prometheus metrics
manage service for Prometheus is split
up into multiple components including
data collection query evaluation rules
and alert evaluation and data storage
for collecting the data Prometheus will
monitor you can make use of the service
in one of two ways manage data
collection or self-deployed data
collection
manage service for Prometheus offers an
operator for manage data collection in
kubernetes environments this operator
runs in your cluster and scrapes the
metric endpoints exposed by your
applications and infrastructure
we recommend that you use managed
collection
using it eliminates the complexity of
deploying scaling sharding configuring
and maintaining Prometheus servers
manage collection is supported for both
gke and non-gk kubernetes environments
with self-deployed data collection you
manage your Prometheus installation as
you always have the only difference from
Upstream Prometheus is that you run the
managed service for Prometheus drop-in
replacement binary instead of the
Upstream Prometheus binary in short
choose manage data collection if you
don't want to take on the responsibility
of managing Prometheus servers
and choose self-deployed if you want the
least change from your current
Prometheus setup another important
activity of Prometheus monitoring is
making queries
promql is the query language to query
data from Prometheus any UI that can
call the Prometheus query API is also
supported in the managed service for
Prometheus that includes grafana and
Cloud monitoring your existing
dashboards in grafana continue to work
just as before and you can keep using
any prom ql found in popular open source
repositories and forums
for Rule and alert evaluation manage
service for Prometheus provides a
standalone rule evaluator that can
evaluate recording and alerting rules
against all Monarch data across multiple
projects no need to co-locate the data
in a single Prometheus server or on a
single Google Cloud project
the rule evaluator uses the standard
Prometheus rule files format making
migration to managed service for
Prometheus easier all managed service
for Prometheus data is stored for 24
months at no additional cost there's
also no limit on the number of active
time series or total time series in this
episode we talked about the Google Cloud
managed service for Prometheus it's a
Best of Both Worlds solution that
enables you to use open source
Prometheus just as you have been while
backing it with Google's Planet scale
time series database Monarch we went
over the basics of your data collection
options either managed via the managed
service with Prometheus operator on any
kubernetes cluster or self-deployed
the managed service supports any query
UI that can call the Prometheus query
API
using grafana and Cloud monitoring UI
you can use promql to query over 1 500
metrics in Cloud monitoring
and we went over the managed service for
Prometheus provided rule evaluator and
data storage characteristics with all
the great features discussed in this
video we hope you can improve the
observability of your kubernetes and
other Cloud workloads you can get
started with manage service for
Prometheus by visiting the Google Cloud
console and checking out the links below
and stay tuned for our next videos where
we dive deeper into other gke topics
foreign
[Music]